we're just getting word Jerrod Nadler  the House Judiciary Committee Chairman  just wrapped up a little impromptu news  conference with reporters up there  saying that he is looking to not only  get robert muller in front of his  committee but he was reacting to the  news that the Attorney General William  bar will not show up and testify Jerry  Nadler saying all options are on the  table as far as a possible subpoena they  have not issued a subpoena as of yet  they also are trying to get the special  counsel robert muller in front of the  House Judiciary Committee on May 15th  that is trying to be locked down but  this is reaction real-time to the  decision by the Attorney General not to  show up at that house hearing tomorrow  we'll continue to cover this throughout  the show